bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi domenica
quindi happy wheels volevo soltanto
dirvi che ieri non ho fatto su motori
nel weekend io faccio su motori e happy
with ieri ho fatto anti chamber che era
un gioco più tranquillo per il semplice
fatto che ieri
diciamo avevo la tosse o comunque la
voce mi è andata via e avevo poca voce e
quindi quando poca voce evito di fare o
giochi horror dove urlo oppure giochi
dove mi diverto come è più visto come
sui motori che urlo rido all'impazzata
mentre oggi che fa che ho fatto è più il
sto peggio di come stavo ieri nel senso
che ieri avevo tasse e non riuscivo a
parlare mentre oggi o tosse non riesco a
parlare e per ultimo anche l'influenza
nel senso che ho proprio la febbre è per
ora gavel avevo promesso io ho una piece
o su motori o tutti e due gli faccio
sempre nel weekend
se per caso domani non metto video o
dopodomani per caso non metto un
episodio è per il fatto che in queste
condizioni è meglio che mi prendo un po
di riposo perché ovviamente se ho la
febbre faccio video non mi passa più e
quindi perdonatemi in anticipo se nel
video avrò la voce un po così e sarà o
meno coinvolgente del solito e colpa
dell'influenza vabbè comunque andiamo là
partiamo subito con ne ha un poco
challenge nel video della scorsa
settimana avevo spiegato che questo
personaggio è mio preferito in assoluto
è praticamente ho deciso di chiamarlo
steve
sì ho trovato anche i nonni poi ve lo
dico a dare innanzitutto mi sono ok mi
sono incastrato tra justin bieber è lo
zio un cazzo vabbè beh mi è uscito il
pogo dal di dietro rifaccio e vabbè dai
pvs è fantastico lo capite perché amo
questo personaggio cioè non è normale
che sia così divertente
bono no occhio che cazzo è successo tra
l'altro raga mi avete consigliato di
fare livelli tipo quello dove l'anci le
spade dove lanci palloni che deve
centrare i punti me li avete consigliati
raga perché avete detto che sono i più
divertenti cos'è sta roba piccola
stupide damon to kill you certo allora
fai così uso la mia arma segreta vai uk
liuc è bravo no no io cosa fai traditore
di merda mi stuprano mi scopro una sulla
bici misto di oh oh cavolo sta già
meglio se sentite sta anche gemendo vi
prego basta
oddio ci provo vabbè comunque il bambino
si chiama luke perché alla fine tra
tutti nomi che sono usciti tim.it molti
e tutti gli altri alla fine il nome da
prendere secondo me e luke baille uk
cose e luke bene c'è oddio oddio mi fa
adesso che cazzo io che sei cresciuto o
merda mi stanno arrivando mista
rimandandosi tutto no che è successo no
no no devo riprovarci un'ultima volta
raga perché hanno capito che è successo
byyou così celli kami perfetto vice bene
e ninja ha posto questo qui mi infilza
sempre ma non mi fa mai nulla lo basava
bene vai così no no nuke se è diventato
lo spedì no look che cazzo è successo
this is sparta mi piace cos'è dai questa
festa con dj madness madness days of
sparta cos'è [ __ ] che figo vabbè
questa era una cosa senza senso ma
meritava di essere fatta the fight game
andiamo con eddy dai che non abbiamo
ancora usato è di the fight game non ho
idea di che cosa sia levelone porca
[ __ ] che cosa è successo è spuntato un
ninja ma sono ancora vivo sono ancora
prendi la spada ma non ho le braccia non
importa prendi dallo stesso
vabbè
e impossibile sto pezzo la caccia non
riesco a fare a meno che non salto prima
se ce l'abbiamo fatta senza gambe
ok sia appunto lo stile delfino dove
siamo nella ok questo è veramente
impossibile non so perché muoio senza
accorgermene
se mi ha tagliato soltanto il pene ma
non importa
facciamo senza oddio ok bene eh va beh
questo è evidentemente difficilissimo e
lasciamo perdere prima di passarci
troppo tempo a mero fatality martello
della fatalità
ok raga il martello di thor che è
partito da solo magari devo afferrarlo
ok ho ucciso a pugni ha ucciso il povero
steve vabbè lasciamo stare
world tour l'ho trovata veramente world
trovo però non importa
ok steve cioè se steve è di farci vedere
che cosa si capace dalla prima uk
benelux non ho neanche sbeccato la
spalla posso rilanciarla riciclaggio
vai così ok due insieme non ho preso non
ho preso nessuno perfetto direttamente
direttamente nelle parti basse vai così
con la bambina la tipo besa non so se la
disco prendere ma mi mancano due spade
allora vai
niente da fare vabbè ci riprovo ok ho
vinto ho vinto senza senza uccidere lo
pesa ma non importa poverina l'offesa
non è considerata e riproviamoci allora
luke togliti non voglio sprecare una
spada per te maledetto bambino idiota
vai via
ma cosa fai lì o fiumi fatti le spade
luke togliti dalle palle togliti non si
gioca con le spade te l'ho detto mille
volte basta la casa rovegno impedito a
non riuscire a finire neanche uno sword
through ma devo farlo sono mica
l'autostima
vai così perfetto per festa siamo con
punto la bambina alla bambina
no cielo quasi ci riprova se l'ultimo
raga stile ninja ora non ce l'ha fatta
va bene è un traguardo già qualcosa
cambiamo mettiamo death of man l'on
non ho capi non ho capito sinceramente
cos'è vicodin che cosa consiste ma non
importa
death of man l'on perfetto look non
giocare a pallone ti ho detto che devi
finire i compiti devo devo solo fare qui
non rischia anche a segno il tronco
perfetto gol
no maledetto la mera parata vabbè non
importa va bene questo e per avermi
parato
il mio tiro splendido perfetto ma sarà
paraga è un'arma alla distruzione di
massa non è un tagliaerba vabbè ed ai
bancari e guarite tutti e due
ok perfetto
malaga ma la gente sparisce dentro
l'altra tagliaerba
va beh non importa noto fest muori
tagliaerba è l'arma che rivoluzionerà
visto il mondo altro che l'ance altro
che pistole altro che nucleari vai anche
babbo natale si è già mamma mia babbo
natale è stato è stato duro da digerire
ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
va bene ma toilet paper ci penso io
tanti 2006
ok triturato l'universo non mi chiedete
dove sono andate a finire i pezzi raich
a questo è un livello che mia mi avete
dedicato mi ha dedicato uno di voi si
chiama nick name and back door ti
ringrazio per aver fatto problemi
dedicato questo livello vai con steve
partiamo subito soldi o quad cadono
televisori ma fa per far vj buy back
door riesce a raggiungere il traguardo
me lo chiedi anche ma scherzi c'è il
traguardo traguardo il mio secondo nome
ok bene facciamo il mio terzo ovviamente
questo era soltanto era riscaldamento
adesso ce la faccio state tranquilli ok
con molta calma e discrezione molta
calma molta calma moltissima calma piano
è impossibile non si può fare c'è
vabbè dai fatto l'hai fatto
difficilissimo cavolo non riesco a
muovermi tipo ok prendo il pogo l'ho
preso lo stesso dopo lo l'ho preso ma si
poteva prendere lo stesso cioè non
pensavo che potessi prendere gli oggetti
una volta che cadono ma lo faccio così
dai dai che ci riesco io e il mio fedele
poco riusciremo ad arrivare verso la
fine lo so non mi deludere poco se la
mia la mia unica speranza sei tu no la
stava schivando tipo matrix ma non ci
sono riuscito come livello è
eccessivamente difficile
ti ringrazio comunque per oggi ho
provato non posso guardo
poi però dovrei stare troppo proviamo ad
un altro proviamo a far punto nel come
idea di che cosa sia by conetti alcun
tunnel proprio vuoto totale
oddio oddio set bye bye obbedito senza
testa senza niente ma ho vinto voglio
capire un attimo carrozza di livello era
perché non ho capito non ha prodotto
giocavamo senza mai se vinco sempre
senza testa ma vinco slow motion slow
motion in via cos'è oddio ma che cazzo
oddio ma che cazzo è successo ok ci
riprova ma non posso tipo salvarmi con
sangue cina se l'ho preso ho preso se no
assassination assassination m'ispira mai
così dio sa a chi l'hai detto io sac
maledetto è di non ti permettere mai
così stronzo cadi come moriremo i
sintomi
ok
va beh niente da dire epic kill epic il
mi ispira no verso un caduto non ho
preso la spada e spada vai così
oddio cos'è sono senza gambe che cazzo
vai così di nuovo ci prova se tutti e
due prendo allora ci prova dalla
distanza
bene colpo di pene sono c'era un vetro
merda vediamo se son riuscito a uccidere
qualcuno col colpo di pene anche se
dubito
sì l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho appreso ok
testa questa me la devo salvare da
vecchie parte c'è è stata la kill più
epica che abbia mai fatto
c'è va beh
lasciamo stare ma veramente è stato
fantastico ho finalmente un bowl droghe
che ha senso ci prova ho già vinto
magari text behind no cassano leggo
niente merda non leggo più nulla
va bene ok è caduto un bidone non so che
cosa ci fosse scritto lì ma è caduto un
bidone si no se ho vinto ho vinto ci
riprovo un secondo perché non ho capito
bene ok
quello era il canestro dello stupro cosa
non ho capito però va beh facciamo finta
di niente io non sono stato mai così di
nuovo di nuovo no no try again
cosa vuol dire te lega no che figo verrà
buttata indietro che hai riproviamoci
ven
[Musica]
vabbè dai sono andato anche abbastanza
culo ma è meglio così l'on gas serra
[Musica]
bike by uk rendimi fiero di te rendi
dove s'è andato io credo che se addio
ok vai braccio vai braccio confine
niente neanche nel braccio vai col thor
so niente sono morto riprovo un secondo
value che rendimento niente rendini un
cazzo senza braccia ma sono ancora vivo
senza neanche la bici senza nulla è
arrivata la bici alla fine il sellino
però lo prendo perché l'ho pagato un
casino no il sellino no di sé che new
escape che cazzo e devo aggrapparmi cosa
ma che cazzo di livello appena giocato
ragazze non sa se no devo devo riuscire
ad aggrapparmi perché è una cosa che fa
abbastanza di prezzo dai no
vabbè la pupù la pupù atomica
ok ragazzaccio l'ultimo knife trout or
drive trough torture
beh che cosa stai facendo look non mi fa
incavolare che ti lancio al posto dei
coltelli guardato va dal e si no che
culo mi stava accadendo sulle spalle mi
mandava tutto a [ __ ] cioè
praticamente io ho vinto senza usarle
spade cioè ho usato soltanto
praticamente e luke vabbè ma vai uk bene
mi mi manca
vabbè manca l'ultimo ma non importa
praticamente ho vinto senza usare
riuscite voglia finire un uno sguardo
trovo senza usarle spade impossibile non
sono anche come ho fatto ma va a finire
che non riesco a ucciderlo l'ultimo no
veramente ci son riuscito va beh manca
soltanto la besa che comunque l'ho già
presa e vabbè comunque classe e sto
facendo tipo l'agopuntura la sua
infilzando con tutte le strade possibili
veramente ciò la voce che domani
probabilmente non parlerò più
comunque trovo un attimo a lanciare
spadea caso perfetto non lo faccio più e
vabbè come al solito se le è piaciuto
video lasciate un commento mi piace qui
sotto anche la pagina di facebook e come
sempre trovate in ogni video nella
descrizione è che dire se non siete
iscritti iscrivetevi cv da un prossimo
video bella ragazzi